quelques clics suffisent sur cette
application dédiée pour commander son
carburant depuis deux ans la société
refoule basée à trappes propose une
station-service ambulante dans les
yvelines ainsi que paris et sa petite
couronne
l'idée est partie d'une expérience
personnelle mon frère et moi nous étions
sur paris et puis un soir nous sommes
tombés en panne d'essence
voilà donc on s'est dit c'est tellement
simple aujourd'hui de se faire livrer
des pizzas de se faire livrer tout un
tas de choses
de là est né un début de projet on a
commencé à chercher vis-à-vis de la
législation des lois des autorisations
et ça nous a pris quatre ans
aujourd'hui l'entreprise d'une vingtaine
de salariés compte une cinquantaine de
clients essentiellement des entreprises
la société s'approvisionnent au dépôt
pétrolier de coignières la flotte est
pour l'instant composé d'une vingtaine
de véhicules
chaque camion un type de carburant
différents et peut transporter neuf cent
soixante litres comme oz géolocaliser
vous avez le même tarif qu'à la station
service la plus proche
ensuite après nous on met une autre
notre prix au service c'est aux
alentours d'un café un peu plus d'un
café on est aux alentours de 2 euros 2
euros 50 refoule propose également le
gonflage des pneus et le nettoyage des
vitres objectifs pour cette année 45
véhicules supplémentaires
le recrutement d'une vingtaine de
salariés et l'élargissement de ce
service aux particuliers et grandes
agglomérations comme lyon ou bordeaux